gene cloning simply means making more
similar kind of DNA it is a lot similar
to a copying machine in the copying
machine you give your input document
which is copied and in a molecular level
you need a machine which can copy your
exact gene of interest and that could be
achieved by bacteria which could work
like a copy machine now in a copying
machine you give your copy of your
document and select the number of copies
and you get the number of copies you
want right now in case of bacteria you
put your gene of interest inside a
plasmid and put the plasmid inside the
bacteria now itself the plasmid is an
extra chromosomal DNA some bacteria
poses more number of plasmid and some
bacteria poses less number of paths
plasmid question is what is the
advantage of having different copy
number of plasmid and because generally
in perspective of a genetic engineering
point of view more copy number plasmid
would be beneficial now let's just try
to look at that how bacteria regulate
their plasmid copy number now one good
thing about the bacteria is if you put
the plasmid inside the bacteria and give
the bacteria proper nutrients and
temperature to grow the bacteria would
grow in their number and our gene of
interest would also grow in their number
right and bacteria should not other the
less that we should of regulate their
plasmid copy number because otherwise it
would cause a huge energy burden into
the bacteria because the many plasmid
would have replication on transcription
demand so that would cause energy burden
and if you have too less amount of
plasmid in the bacteria then there is a
possibility that over generations the
plasmid would get lost and most of this
plasmid encodes for antibiotic
resistance and in other important stuff
so if the plasmid is lost then it could
be detrimental for the bacteria and even
compromise its survival ability right
now the question comes how do they
regulate their plasmid copy number so
here is a plasmid which would be
replicated to two identical plasmid
and the replication starts from the
origin of replication sight now near the
origin of replication site there is a
portion of the DNA which encodes for an
RNA which is known as RNA - and the same
DNA segment in an opposite direction
transcribes and forms RNA one and B's to
RNA are the important players to
regulate plasmid copy number one of the
most important of them is RNA to harden
it to binds to the origin of replication
when the replication bubble is forming
and RNase H family sort of cleaves the
tail of RNA - which would serve as a
primer and the replication can start
from there now you can understand that
if the + Factory has a high plasmid
number then RNA 2 is mostly transcribed
in that particular bacteria right on
other hand side RNA 1 which is exactly
transcribed from the opposite strand of
RNA - so they are complementary to each
other it could also be produced and it
can face pair with RNA 2 now as a result
when RNA 1 and RNA 2 is making a hybrid
the RNase H cannot bind and no primer
for replication is there so replication
can not start now plus me the bacteria
cannot make new copies of the plasmid
right so most of the low copy number
back here has these RNA 1 and RNA to
production simultaneously as a result
copies number if in a chip now what
happens apart from me the RNA one is
already too
it is another important protein which is
encoded by a nearby region to the origin
of replication known as RP o 1 ROP one
group one is the Brooke one there's an
important thing rope one generally binds
to RNA to and facilitate the binding of
RNA 1 and as a result it prevent the
replication to happen but preventing the
RNA is h2 pine right
and not allowing it to form the primer
for replication initiation and here is
some example of high copy number plasmid
and low copy number plasmid so pbr3 22
which is a well-known plasmid is
actually a low copy number whereas PUC
19 is a high copy number plasmid so when
we say a low copy number plasmid it has
only 10 to 20 copies of the plasmid per
cell whereas in case of the high copy
number plasmid it has 500 to 700 copies
per cell now I hope you understand the
concepts behind copying implies mid copy
number of regulation if you like my
video and if you have specific questions
please let me know in the comment
section thank you